we welcome our friend from good morning
football uh back on the show and he's
back with 10 questions with kyle brent
we're all
um we're uh on the ringer in spotify uh
that's where his podcast can be gotten
how are you kyle brandt
i'm good and i'm intrigued rich by what
i just heard regarding uh lamar jackson
the reigning mvp
of the league in the middle of the
season saying he's going under center
and
am i correct in saying he told you
defenses are calling out what play the
ravens are gonna run
kyle um i asked him my first question
was like it looks like things are coming
tougher this year it's not as easy as
last year looked
what would you say to that and he
basically said it part of his answer was
the defense is calling a lot of our
plays out before the snap
and i said what do you mean and he
basically said run past like he's
you know and as you know there's no fans
in the stands so it's much easier to
communicate where
you know in certain places there there
are some fans but not the same amount
i i that was one of those moments as an
interviewer like did i
did i kind of catch that one you know
i'm having that moment as a guest
i'm like did the host just say that he
asked the prior guest and that's what
they said rich that's a big
big bite especially since i mean as you
know like
the ravens are national this week of all
the teams to play against when you think
they might know what you're running
uh they're playing they're doing the
patriots so that i mean that's
i'm i'm staggered by that bite yeah
that's what he said earlier today uh
earlier today but it you know also said
that dez is already
a leader on the team that was of of
interest to hear is that um
that he's already chiming in and he also
you know confirmed what john harbaugh
had mentioned earlier today it looks
like ingram's going to be back
so what do you think of the ravens here
that's kind of the afc team that
we're not really like once the steelers
beat him
uh we've kind of put to the wayside a
little bit thinking this is the chiefs
and steelers world and we're now focused
on the thursday night game first up
uh with the colts and the titans what do
you think of the steelers so f
of the ravens so well i think i think
you brought it up perfectly
they need some energy they need a little
bit of uh of the moxie of the party of
the swagger
um they're a very good team they're
they're one of the other guys though
you know the word elite is not getting
attached to baltimore ravens right now
because
and that's that's welcome to the new
reality ravens fans want to complain you
give us no credit give us no credit i'm
giving you a compliment
i'm saying that you great things are
expected of the baltimore ravens super
bowl thing so
six and two for a lot of teams you're
having mardi gras but when you lose to
pittsburgh and you lose again to kansas
city and you just sort of feel like
a little flat and i think i i think
there's a reason that mark ingram has
been out
he's the energizer and dez bryant is
instant energy
and the fact that they need that is a
little alarming if i'm one of those
other guys in the wide receiver room
of which they are not massive names uh i
would say
why are you bringing in dez bryant we're
not doing enough you're going to bring a
guy who hasn't played in a couple of
years who
his best football is allegedly behind
him i would be motivated by that
so if they have a point where their
energy is a little flat and they're
getting back their guy in ingram and
they're getting dez bryant who i don't
know if he can catch a ball or not but i
know he brings passion
it's it's time to go we are not early we
are not we're we are in the back half
as you know rich and if the ravens are
gonna take a run at this thing it's time
to start playing good ball
i agree with you uh where do you stand
on the nfc now that the
saints boat race the bucks um seattle
got
smoked by buffalo we did see tua
go toe to toe with kyler murray green
bay
did uh start the week with a win but it
was against a san francisco b
or c team where what what are your
thoughts right now on the nfc going into
the back half of the season
well saints box was um a staggering game
i i mean it's it
i i couldn't believe what i was saying i
felt like a lot of the other people and
i remember going into that game
trying you're trying to pick how it's
going to go and they're both teams are
so good and everything and it's
it occurred to me that one of them was
was a really good team
and i was worried that one of them was a
really good collection of parts
and that turned out to be exactly what
it was with tampa bay being the
collection of parts and
it's like that game it felt like if you
were to play a seven game series or even
one game
would you rather have the world champion
los angeles lakers the regular roster
or would you rather have the eastern
all-star team with giannis and everybody
who goes
with it i think you'd rather have the
lakers because they're a real team
they're not a collection of toys and
that's what tampa bay looked like to me
the play that killed me that night was
that really bad looking interception on
the far side to antonio brown
where they were not in the same chapter
of the same book of the same volume
encyclopedia britannica
antonio brown pulled up short brady
through long and again i'm kind of
thinking
what is he doing out there they needed
him on that team and i know it was we're
gonna we're gonna take it to the next
level and
we're gonna win a super bowl with this
move and that's the move i don't know
you had
really good receivers and you bring in a
really mercurial at best guy and now
it's hurting the football
i uh i have a friend with the tampa bay
buccaneers rich
that i text with sometimes pretty high
up guy and i remember a couple of
weekends ago
when it happened happened on saturday
night i think when they got antonio and
it was happening i text and i go are you
guys really bleeping getting antonio
brown
and all he texts back was a gif and it
was a gif of a poker player pushing a
giant stack of chips right to the middle
of the table
and uh listen it's a huge gamble and i
did not like what i saw never mind the
off the field stuff which is
unsavory to say the lightest the anfield
was off too
and if brady's going to sit there and
force it to the guy who stays in his
house all the time i don't know throw it
to heavens and god one it was a really
weird night
and that leaves me in a long-winded way
to answer your question i guess the
saints right now are the truth
just the team that we don't know if we
can trust in the playoffs so everybody
buckle up
yeah i know and seattle's defense is uh
on pace to use the sports phrase of
some pretty unprecedentedly bad numbers
and we saw the bills slice them up now
we'll see what happens with the rams
coming off of the bye week
um and you know i i just don't
want to sleep on green bay i just don't
want to sleep
on them because again
just because there's only three players
on their team that fantasy
owners have does not mean they're not a
super bowl contender
you know you're going through robert
don't call me tanyan compliment
seriously those guys be like you know
i'm looking at your team
and you're wildly flawed i don't mean
just uh
you know the baseball card has a little
bit of a corner that's pulled back like
the thing is messed up it's it's not
it's not even close to a perfect team
but it still feels like a onus wagner
like aaron rodgers it still feels that
good
um heavily flawed team i look at them i
think
we're inevitably going to see rich for
the ninth time in their careers
russell wilson versus aaron rodgers
because both i feel like they're the
same team prolific quarterbacks
wildly flawed teams that i don't think
are good enough to win a super bowl but
are going to run into each other
for the ninth time and uh they're four
and four and the home team always wins
so
i love those teams too but as in the
same breath that you say
i love green bay and i do too i didn't
even recognize them against tampa
who i didn't even recognize against new
orleans the snake is eating its tail
i know i you know it's it's saints beat
uh
bucks um you know who beat packers
who you know and it just goes on and on
and on and they were in the movie with
kevin bacon
they were in fact just
a couple of steps removed from flash uh
from uh
from all sorts of footloose and all that
stuff yeah
um so and then there's the monday
nighter
where there's a a three and five team uh
with uh a lot better and more going for
it than the five and four team
uh and i'm just i mean that's that's
that's the fact
that's a fact and it it it feels like
the bears are the ones that
whose season is basically over and
they're playing out of string and
they're the ones who are a game and a
half in front of the vikings
because of the way that they've looked
the last couple weeks respectively these
two teams
what i keep i i don't mean to keep
throwing it on you but i know you're a
bearish guy
um do you think we're going to reach the
point um
this monday maybe of lamenting the fact
that trubisky's
not healthy enough to be an option that
we finally have reached that part yeah
what you're looking for for the bears is
you're just craving you're just
thirsting for rock bottom so we can
start to rebuild which is why i welcome
the question i'm glad you brought it up
i did um kind of a a strange experiment
on sunday i was watching the game on my
couch and i was just
i knew it was going to be miserable i
was under no delusion all of a sudden
they're going to start pulling
touchdowns out of their backside
i wrote down as the game was happening
what the bears drives were to start the
game
rich i'm not making this up this is the
chicago bear offense
through three quarters against the
tennessee titans defense which has been
lit up this is how the drives went as
followed
turn over on downs punt
punt punt punt
punt half time punt
fumble which is returned for a touchdown
by the defense that's the three quarters
that's what we're at and now we're just
going to sit in it
because monday night you play the
vikings national television it's you
just sit in it and everyone's going to
watch it's like pain in the bathtub
there's nowhere that you're going to sit
in it and enjoy it
and that's your mess that you made and
now dalvin cook's gonna run for another
200 yards so i think we're at the rock
bottom i think we made it there
ah all of a season richard and yet
you know uh if you want to talk rock
bottom
um kyle not to go toe to toe with you
here
rocco rock bottom to me would to be uh
be up by 10 on your hated rivals in
division
in front of a monday night football
audience yeah um
getting set to um shock them by handing
them their
fifth consecutive loss for the first
time since the mid 90s
um and then only possessed the ball
for 84 seconds throughout a fourth
quarter in which
your four plays that you do have is an
interception
on the first draw a first play uh and
then
um a uh a dump off over the middle to
your
running back uh to keep the clock
rolling a little bit to make sure the
other team doesn't just get the ball
right back but then you do give him the
ball right back
by taking a sack and then uh snapping
the ball with 18
seconds left on the play clock uh and
then losing
um and then losing um that to go to 0-9
i'd i'd say that's rock bottom
that's it's that's what i was that's a
weird fever dream watching that team
it's joe flacco throwing passes to frank
gore
it's like a jets comic-con where
everyone's
dressed up in their jets costumes but
not uniforms and it really did happen
i was cracking up the other day rich i
want to hear your thoughts on this i'm
channel surfing
and i don't get to see it much anymore i
used to watch it a lot when i was young
but i stumbled upon the last couple
minutes of
pti and they were lamenting tony and
mike about the jets
and they were saying that the only jets
highlight in history in the entire
history of the organization
is joe namath with the finger point as
he runs off that's the only one
and i said that can't possibly be true
is that the only one
well i mean it's the only one in which
they won the super bowl i mean
right now another high like a great
great iconic
i guess can't wait from bart scott is
pretty good after beating the patriots
yeah but that was the divisional round i
mean and
not unless you forget the butt fumble
man
i mean that's why i mean you could you
could yes
you could make uh um you know a list of
the
the famous highlight moments
of the jets and then a list of the
famous
highlight in quote moments for the jets
that would have the butt fumble and
obviously the fake spike from mourinho
and we could we could go on it's
probably a longer list it is but
i don't know why i need to be kicked in
the teeth that way too
certainly with i was trying to search
for solutions i can't find anything
especially you know and i worked myself
up yesterday i frequently do when it
comes to the subject of this team that
steve young was the latest to say to
trevor lawrence you don't want to go to
the jets
and you know and as i pointed out
yesterday i mean like
trevor lawrence could be uh broadway
trevor by going to new york and i know
that they've broken sam darnold but they
would
absolutely get the cream of the crop
coach who wouldn't want to be attached
to trevor lawrence's hip
right off the get-go in new york city
right i mean who wouldn't want to do
that right now in a division
that uh is habitually even though it
does appear to be better
but habitually so low that tom brady in
year 20 gets swept by a division
opponent for the first time in his
career yes
so you know who wouldn't do that
especially since two if you want to talk
about
marketing uh you take a solid receiver
slot receiver and he does a single salsa
dance
um and he still has a career 10 years
after playing you know i mean
let's let's let's let's let's just talk
about what the what new york city really
is that's
yeah i don't know i mean larger than
life justin tuck
sold five dollar foot longs for you know
for a decade man i mean
so that might have been strahan too so
uh all right before i let you go kyle
you've got
joel mchale right that's who's your
guest i know he's a friend of yours as
well
uh he did an unbelievable job on ten
questions had a his an historic
final score and we got into talking
about hosting rich you would love it and
i was he had so many different types of
jobs and i was you know i tried to ask
him like
what was the most challenging or was the
most exhilarating he tells this story
of hosting the white house
correspondents dinner
and oh my goodness now he got to do it
second term obama so there's no election
looming everyone's just relaxed but he
gets up in that room
and there's a million politicians a
million powerful people there's a few
years ago so
chris christie jokes were big at the
time uh jessica simpson was there and he
did a 20-minute roast of everybody
in the room the way he tells the story
about is the script run by the white
house do they look at it do they cross
things out
absolutely amazing i was dying at the
end of it he has to follow the president
too so
you know joel you've had him on like he
is razor sharp the way he tells the
story and the way he gets into all
the stories of his career it was one of
the best ones we've ever done that's
great ten questions with kyle brandt
podcast available again the ringer in
spotify
previous guests to check out adam devine
uh pat and oswell tim robbins
obviously so much to talk about with him
um and again it's every wednesday a new
episode drops as the kids would say
uh but before i do let you go uh i'd
love to help have you help
us here at the show last week we did
um a segment um based on uh the water
boy being in theaters uh 22 years prior
it was an anniversary the water boy
uh which nfl player deserved first
overall pick status and we chose
fictional nfl player uh we chose bobby
boucher
johnny utah willie beeman and forrest
gump and
daniel jeremiah called in i don't know
if you saw it but he stuck the landing
with
he had he had scouting reports on all
four of the guys it was amazing
he was a glistening appearance by dj
i believe he said that boucher uh plays
better than he measures or bigger than
he than he weighs
and it was as if he was breaking down
any prospect you've ever heard coming
out
from andy katzenmoyer to luke lee it was
so good and so that's such a great
idea and he was right by the way i i was
fascinated by boucher's immeasurable
bouche
probably better in the 70s there were a
lot more contact there was still the
wedge busting factor on special teams
now probably a lot of personal files but
i love the dj's breakdown and i'm team
boucher as well
right and one of the one of the red
flags for forrest gump is he was just a
straight line runner he had problems
he's just fantastic so we're thinking
about my concerns on utah of course
uh it was really really good um not as
good as something else though rich and i
would be loath if i did not bring this
up
and i i made sure that when i called in
today i wanted to say something about
this
uh please allow me to say how happy
impressed and if i may
proud i was of you on sunday during game
day morning when you
clearly broke free from your planned
rundown
and your format for the show that
morning and
gave that incredible speech about alex
trebek who had just passed i'm sure in
the middle of the show
uh i was standing uh applauding
thanks man so good and i'm so glad you
did that oh thanks kyle i appreciate
that i mean
the guy's a television icon of
broadcasting legend and obviously
you know uh merited even on a football
show
uh pausing and and paying respects and
for me personally i mean um he he's one
of the all-time greats i
i i actually wrote down in my notes the
greatest of all time and then i thought
there's bob barker who's still alive as
well
and by i mean you know alex rebecca and
bob barker are truly
two of the greatest broadcasters of all
time so i definitely wanted to say that
but the and i appreciate you saying that
the reason why i brought all of this up
is we're
um thinking of recycling this idea as we
always do
in this in this uh in this business that
we are in where we come up with content
every day
uh before i let you go we want to do it
because the nba drafts next week we want
to come up with four
fictional movie basketball characters
the problem is though is unlike football
characters
basketball characters are mostly played
by actual basketball players and movies
so we're not gonna come up with a list
of players is who's worthy of being
drafted as a lottery pick
and the choices are essentially
shaquille o'neal penny hardaway and ray
allen you know what i mean like we're
not gonna do that
so we've come up with a handful of them
wondering if we're
if there's any that we're missing um i'd
love to hear what you got
we've decided on jackie moon makes the
card jackie moon yeah
jackie moon makes the cut uh okay billy
hoyle
billy hoyle makes it happen yeah we're
thinking about teen wolf
teen wolf making the cut yeah bud i like
yeah i just i don't know if we can go i
don't know if we can all right now
jimmy chitwood maybe talking about scott
howard in teen wolf are we talking about
the wolf
i think we're talking about the walls
i'm at the wolf i'm talking about the
actual okay
yeah we're talking about the wolf um i
have some takes on that and i've watched
the game tape exhaustively
the wolf one of the more overrated
players and i'll tell you why
it's it's purely a sort of russell west
brookian
explosion to the basket we know he
doesn't pass or share the ball or make
anybody better but we never get to see
the wolf
hit a shot from anywhere outside the
paint i don't think the wolf can shoot
so if he's going to line up ever against
the defensive stopper in the bruce bowen
or raja bell mold
i think the wolf could really be a
liability on the team i don't think the
wolf has a shot oh the wolf is like ben
simmons he
can't shoot yes i think they're just
backing off the wolf
staring at him to shoot making fun of
him cracking jokes at booth
to incite his rage which he also has and
we saw it at the bowling alley as the
tempers off the
off the court concerns and i don't think
he has the mid-range or a deep jumper
so maybe that's a problem we can't even
consider him
because again smith prince we're
thinking of throwing this in front of
billis next week i got to call him to
check it out
well he's the guy um but yeah air bud
sure uh like mike
um jimmy chitwood of course mike
wait a minute lil bow wow from like mike
yeah
with the shoes obviously right yes with
the magic shoes
marvin the martian they put some key
buckets in the game against against the
mom stars
there's lots of potential for bench but
for your starters you might want to
think like mike
does jimmy chitwood make it i know he's
a high school player and obviously he
was the best player on hickory
but uh but i don't think he probably had
much of a college career
you know no pure shooter also
coachability concerns
uh it desires his own shots he listens
to his coach sometimes so i'm a little
worried about that but i mean listen
if you can work on them if you mold them
if you have an educator as your head
coach because that's the next question
who's going to who's going to coach this
team good question
all right so did you have the gene
hackman character do you i don't know is
it bill murray
samuel l jackson yeah whoopi goldberg of
course yeah
do you want a man yeah
do we have joanna man do we go do we go
with jewel
how about um no hold on what about um
what about that whoopee play a coach
right was that yeah
eddie eddie eddie yeah i like that yeah
yeah we'll be whoopi will uh get those
guys in line i think we're we're we're
around the edges here we're workshopping
it but jackie moon is in and billy
hoyle's incorrect
agreement those two are in all right we
got two more spots
for our dean not on the team and billy
hoyle is isn't he more talented
that's not a bad one i mean ball handler
explosive
you know he's a little talk to talk i
i'd almost rather work with dean's
talent than
hoyle because as we know hoyle you know
has not can't jump it's actually the
name of the man that gets ruined for me
because in real life wesley snipes
terrible basketball player
is that right okay well i didn't know
that thanks the reality of this is
yeah let's just we need to suspend our
disbelief
okay in real life i don't think the air
bud dog can take uh the basketball in
its mouth and shoot and michael j fox is
not
actually wearable thank you for the call
kyle we appreciate it as always you take
care
of it thanks man yeah you got it that's
kyle brown at kyle brandt
on twitter check him out good morning
football every day 7 a.m and then of
course
every wednesday the latest episode of 10
questions with kyle brandt joel mchale
is his guest